[Music]
foreign
hello there it's good to have you with
us you're watching the Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines uh let's have a look at the
front page of the Daily Mail their
headline 24 hours to save them
unsurprisingly that story is leading
many of the front pages tomorrow
the Metro also leading with the last
photo of the submersible before its
Journey to the wreck
the sun interviews a man who says he was
booked to travel on the missing vessel
meanwhile The Daily Star says the
missing submersible is steered by a 42
pound video game controller
the chancellors summoned banks for
mortgage talks but rules out Aid to
homeowners that's on tomorrow's front
page of the financial times
the eye goes further leading with a
warning that the Tories face a UK
mortgage time bomb
while the guardian leads with mortgage
Time Bomb bailout calls split tories
the covert pandemic damaged a generation
of young people that's on the front of
the Daily Telegraph
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by journalists
and broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the
mail on Sunday's acting Deputy political
editor Claire Ellicott great to have you
both with us thanks so much for joining
us uh Jenny let's kick off with the
front page of the Metro like many of
tomorrow's papers leading on the missing
sub at their headline Titanic sub last
photo and focusing very much on this
Race Against Time in terms of the amount
of oxygen they're estimating the team
have left
yes and also the fact that more details
are emerging about the five people
believed to be inside uh this
submersible uh three britons one aged
just 19. uh but three of them there's a
father and son that's the 19 year old is
the son three of them are thought to be
very experienced deep sea adventurers
um this has shown a light on a very
expensive kind of adventuring it's sort
of disaster tourism that may have turned
into a disaster itself or at least uh
wrecked tourism uh they paid 200 000
pounds of Passenger they've gone down or
tried to go down 3 800 meters that's as
as low as the ounce as High
um Extraordinary People in terms of
wealth but also willingness to to take
on a really serious Adventure
um I guess so those details have been
emerging today and also the fact that
other people who have uh been on the
Titan this uh submarine to go down to
see the Titanic have been talking about
how they uh knew of the risks or perhaps
suspected there were great risks and had
to sign waivers going down it is 48
hours since it lost contact and we found
out today from the U.S Coast Guard that
um there are around 40 hours of
breathable air left inside there which
means that uh by sort of Thursday
morning our time uh the air is going to
run out so it is a Race Against Time and
it is a search and rescue mission both
parts of that are incredibly difficult
searching an area as large as Wales and
trying to rescue people that far uh deep
down so there is a kind of
you know incredible symmetry about this
it's like a disaster movie uh of a
famous historical
um disaster is there going to be another
massive loss of life here
um it's rare for things to go wrong on
submersible so lots of questions are
being asked in the papers but for now we
just have no idea what's going on uh
aboard the submarine
yeah Claire The Daily Mail I'm also
leading with this story tomorrow morning
I was thanking someone today it really
reminds me of of the coverage of the
young football team in Thailand who are
trapped in that cave and the whole world
was rooting for them but this time it
does seem to be far more challenging
because there's just absolutely no idea
where they are and of course there's a
huge expanse that they have to search
I mean this is truly the stuff of
nightmares there's five people trapped
in this tiny object it's only 22 foot
long I think and they are thousands
probably thousands of meters Under the
Sea surface
um it's absolutely impossible to search
the sea
um you know they talk about the surface
of the Moon being better explored than
some of the depths of the ocean it
absolutely is just an impossible task
and the Coast Guard and all of the other
agencies involved are truly in a Race
Against Time there are 40 hours of air
they estimate left in this submarine
um it's unimaginable what the people in
there are going through it's it's just
and for their families as well and it's
it's a fact that you know diving is a
dangerous Endeavor they've gone down I
think it's 13 000 Feet Under the Sea the
Titanic is uh the Titanic wreck is
located and they were in really
difficult weather conditions and before
they did the dive and you know they we
just don't know where they are the U.S
Coast Guard as though they've had no
luck so far they've searched thousands
and thousands of feet of the ocean and
we see with um planes with with boats
and also I think they've got underwater
drones looking for these people but it
is a really really difficult task and it
is a real Race Against Time and um it
must be just unimaginable what what
their families are going through at the
moment
um it truly is you know a real real
Reckoning absolutely I was I was
speaking to one of the experts we've
been interviewing earlier and I said you
know it's it's a needle in a haystack
situation and he said it would be easier
to find a needle in a haystack it really
doesn't bear thinking about but let's
hold our breath there's still time and
there's still hope let's move on to one
of the other main stories leading some
of the papers uh tomorrow Jenny the
front page the financial times very much
focusing on this uh concern over
people's mortgages uh one Tory MP
calling it a mortgage bomb about to go
off
yeah a mortgage Time Bomb about to go
off that was that was Jake Berry of uh
of uh one of the northern uh research
group red wall uh seats
um Martin Lewis the the big money saving
expert has also used this phrase
mortgage time but I'm about to go off it
is really worrying for people and there
are millions of people I'm one of them
uh who are facing the end of their
mortgage deals and uh seeing a huge jump
in interest rates tomorrow we are going
to see the latest set of inflation
figures and inflation is expected to be
down but not very much not by very much
we have um
still the most stubborn inflation and
the highest level inflation of all the
G7 countries and Jeremy Hunt says he
cannot provide assistance to people who
have mortgages because that would make
inflation worse but he's under pressure
from from his fellow MPS to do so I mean
this kind of thing is is a real uh you
know vote winner or rather it affects
people at The Ballot Box and not just
people who have mortgages renters are
facing an enormous squeeze rents are
going up apparently more renters are
paying a greater proportion of of their
wage on rent than they have done for for
many years simply because mortgage rates
are so high and interest rates are of
course expected to go up yet again this
year to the highest levels since 2008 so
it is frightening times for a lot of
people and what's really worrying is
that things don't seem to be getting
better Jeremy Hunt has said that he's
going to talk to Banks and banks are
going to help uh lenders on a uh they're
going to help people with mortgages on a
Case by case basis help people out if
they can't pay but it's not so much a
question of not being able to pay there
are a lot of people who will just about
manage to pay but they are not going to
be able to save any money spend any any
money and as we know uh interest rates
are going up and they're going up on
mortgages but we're not feeling them so
much on our savings so um Bleak times
ahead I would say
yeah it is rather believed it's hot it's
hard to dress this up uh isn't it Claire
at the front page of the Guardian also
leading with this line of mortgage uh
time bomb and we could of course see
interest rates go up again on Thursday
uh and I I find it quite interesting to
read earlier that 400 000 people are
gonna see their current uh mortgage
deals end between July and September
yes this is a real worry for the Tories
we're going into an election next year
so Jeremy Hunt is under real pressure to
do something as the chancellor but the
facts are that if you start pumping
money into into the system you you will
in theory trigger more inflation which
is one of the reasons why costs are so
high at the moment anyway so they're in
a really difficult bind and they're
coming out of real pressure from a lot
of their MPS Jake Berry as we just
mentioned
um he's he's one of the he's from a red
Aussie and the northern research group
of Tory MPS but in actual fact I think
the some of the blue walls some of the
Tories kind of more traditional
supporters down south are going to be
really really hard hit by this and um
the rates are going up a lot you know
these are real noticeable differences
from most homeowners and um you know
it's not just affecting people at the
lower end of the scale it's affecting
people in the middle classes who may
find that their mortgages beyond what
they can afford to pay and the Specter
of negative equity and you know people
having to default on their loans is is a
real worry so this is I think why Jeremy
Hunt has called in the bank
um I think on Friday to have to speak to
them about what possibly they can do but
the realities are that there aren't many
levers at his control or even at the
bank's control because this problem is
um ingrained and we've got sluggish
growth you know there's there's high
levels of inflation they're persistent
that have seem to be coming down despite
as being one of British students real
priorities and um the facts are that
they're these costs are being passed
onto homeowners which are you know the
key group of Voters that Tories need to
keep happy and it's really looking
perilous for the year ahead yeah
certainly Jenny's it's so worrying for
so many people who are already
struggling to make ends meet and as
Claire was saying there you know Jeremy
Hunt is meeting with lenders on Friday
but the government has already said that
they're not going to intervene
financially
yeah I mean there's there's only so much
that that lenders can do as I said
before they can help with people who are
in Desperate circumstances by helping
them out without affecting their their
credit rating but there's nothing really
they can do and you know Claire mentions
a general election coming up in 2024.
there are many by-elections coming up
within a few months and in fact um the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves made the
point today quite clever really she she
found out she did some number crunching
found out that 10 100 households in uh
Boris Johnson's old seat of Oxbridge uh
are going to be facing average mortgage
costs that are an extra 2 700 pounds a
year people think about this stuff uh
because obviously the labor party are
spinning this as being a direct
consequence of Liz truss's mini budget
of course uh the conservatives would
like to say that it's a consequence of
the war in in Ukraine economic factors
beyond their control but I think most
people feel that this is an avoidable
crisis that this comes out of mistake
the conservatives have made and they
have lost their reputation for financial
competence Jeremy Hunt is trying to claw
that back but this is something that
they need to address and not just before
the next general election they need to
address it now before all of these
by-elections
um Claire let's just squeeze in another
story before the break front page of the
financial times is also covering uh this
story of Hunter Biden Joe Biden's son
who's been charged with federal crimes
it's really interesting isn't it because
this is a story that's been followed
very closely for a long time now in the
U.S but hasn't really cut through here
in the UK in the same way
yes I mean hunter Biden has been a way
of attacking Joe Biden since he became
the president he's the sort of weak Link
in the president's camp and we've all
seen those photos of him he's you know
he's he's in the path had addictions
he's um you know admitted to all sorts
of things and we've now seen these new
charges and the facts are that he you
know he is the convenient stick to beat
Joe Biden with and you know the
president's kind of enemy in the
Republican Camp will be making as much
as they can of this
um but you know Joe this is a member of
Joe Biden's family you know there's not
really
um you know there's not much he can do
about it it's it's it's just a sort of
ongoing worry for the president but
um you know it remains to be seeing what
will happen as a result of this but it
does seem like everyone in the US in the
future presidential election doesn't
seem rather embroiled in the series of
court cases at the moment and um you
know it'll be very interesting to run up
to the election what what happens there
yeah it's contagious it's isn't it and
certainly um Jenny I mean it was to be
expected Donald Trump came out speaking
very critically calling this a mere
traffic ticket for Hunter Biden today
but but some comparing his situation
with with the legal challenges facing
Donald Trump saying he should also just
accept some charges and avoid going to
trial
well this this massively plays into
Donald Trump's hands because he can say
that the Department of Justice is is on
Biden's side and is uh is letting his
son off uh with a wrap on the knuckles
uh you know Hunter Biden is a private
individual and Donald Trump he faced
these federal charges for things that he
directly
um had done but nonetheless this this
very much plays into how Donald Trump
wants to spin things he has been going
on about Hunter Biden and his laptop for
many many years Hunter Biden has had
troubles for many years too troubles uh
with addiction he's been struggling for
a very long time but he is not running
to be president like Donald Trump is or
uh his dad is running for for
re-election What's significant about
this is the narrative that allows Donald
Trump to uh to spin about a corrupt
system uh designed to be unfair to him
and this is something that will play
really well I think with Donald Trump
supporters okay Jenny Claire we'll give
you a bit of a breather see you in just
a moment thank you so much do stay with
us we'll have more of our press preview
next including this on the front of the
telegraph at their headline lockdown
damaged a generation says X CMO that's
the former Chief medical officer we'll
be speaking about that after this short
break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview it's good to have you with us
and with me uh this evening it's Jenny
cleeman and Claire Ellicott uh kicking
off again on some of the front pages and
the stories in tomorrow's newspapers um
Claire Let's uh let's speak about what's
on the front page of the Daily Telegraph
if I may the covert inquiry a really
emotional testimony today from the
former Chief medical officer describing
lockdown as damaging a generation
yeah so this is um Sally Davies the
former Chief medical officer she's been
giving evidence to the covert inquiry
and what she said is that lockdown was
really damaging for a generation of
children and for everyone else that was
involved as well now we all know how
um you know how difficult it was for the
country for the for the government to
put the country into lockdown and um the
real kind of um you know kind of
consequences of this are only really
being seen now you have so many children
who Miss so much schooling and people at
University who Miss schooling people at
work who just didn't get you know the
opportunities they should have done and
do you know Miss the chances to
socialize with their colleagues and to
have a like well-rounded life and you
know it's been a really really difficult
time for so so many people and um the
real and you know the the chief former
Chief medical officer really emphasized
that the facts are that you know
lockdown wasn't very good for the
country and um especially not children
at school who weren't able to go to
lessons we've seen you know the
government's tried to put in place some
catch-up lessons but it just hasn't had
the effect that it should have done and
you know they've not been able to do the
same to just have the same opportunities
they would have done and it's really
been difficult for a whole generation of
people and um you know the facts are
that the covert is over now but we are
still seeing the lasting effects of many
of those decisions that were made at the
time Jenny I saw you shaking your head
uh at moments there I'll let you jump in
with with whatever you want to say
yes of course no doubt kovid was very
damaging and it was perhaps most
damaging for for young people who are
least at risk of covid but but I think
Dane Sally Davis was not was not saying
that lockdown shouldn't have happened
because at the time we didn't have a
vaccine and we didn't have any
alternatives and I think the Daily
Telegraph is very anti-lockdown has
certainly shown itself to be so over the
past few months or so with it with its
disclosure of of lots of things to do
with Matt Hancock's what's that it has
it has an agenda I'm a mother myself I
saw my uh children denied so many
important years of their of their lives
at school
um but you know what what was the
alternative that we let a lot of people
die I mean one of the things that Dame
Sally said today was that nobody thought
about lockdowns but that's because they
were Unthinkable at the time I mean
nobody ever considered that in a
democratic country that the state could
order people to stay at home but at time
we did not know about covid we did not
know about the risk we didn't know who
was at risk and it was the only option
that we had so it's incredibly sad that
people have have been so badly affected
by lockdown and yes a generation has
been harmed but what was the alternative
that we simply uh allowed hundreds of
thousands of people to die that's even
more Unthinkable I would say and can I
just a final thought from you it was
interesting we heard from um George
Osborne as well who defended austerity
today
Claire can you hear me okay
sorry yes and so George Osborne yes the
former Chancellor he um he put in place
a number of um people in place a number
of of you know policies that meant that
that you know that some of the services
that were available to people didn't get
the same sort of funding that they had
done in the park he's been blamed
obviously for not being prepared for the
pandemic as a result of that
um he's obviously defended himself and
said that you know this wasn't to blame
but there were some members of the
conservative government have in the past
said that you know there wasn't there
wasn't the things in place to
um enable us to cope with this pandemic
in the same way that uh in the way that
we should have done and um you know we
saw there was a lack of PPE there was a
lack of sort of integral planning which
meant that it was really difficult to
put those Supply chains in place when we
needed them and um you know it was a
real struggle to sort of get the country
through this and we saw time and again
that you know there were contract handed
out to people who weren't deserving of
them there was so much taxpayers money
wasted and it was a real real error on
the part of some of those who planned it
um in making sure that the country had
what it needed okay Claire Jenny thanks
so much we'll see you again next hour